Security is an ever-growing concern for development teams.
Many organizations are beginning to shift left,
catching vulnerabilities before they reach production.
But security shouldn't make life difficult for developers.
That's why we built Dastidly,
a free containerized DAST web application scanner
for your CI CD pipeline from Burp Suite.
You may not have heard of Burp Suite,
but your pen testers will have.
It's the world's leading toolkit for web security testing,
used by over 16,000 organizations worldwide.
And Dastidly is based on the exact same groundbreaking Burp Scanner.
It looks at your application from the outside in,
just like an attacker.
As a result, it's far less prone to producing false positives,
giving it the sort of accuracy that most static analysis tools can only dream of.
It's completely platform and language agnostic.
You can run it anywhere you run a Docker container,
including CI CD platforms such as GitHub, TeamCity and Jenkins.
Every time you deploy your web application,
Dastidly scans for seven key web security vulnerabilities.
And best of all, it's completely free.
No account, login or payment details needed.
Just set up and go.
It just takes a few lines of code to add Dastidly to your existing pipeline.
Just add your target site and off you go.
Once Dastidly has been added as a stage in your workflow,
it'll begin working its scanning magic.
It's super quick, with scans taking less than 10 minutes to run,
so it won't hold up your build.
Results are displayed in an easy-to-consume JUnit XML report,
providing fast, instant feedback directly in your CI CD pipeline.
Reports include free actionable advice from our Web Security Academy,
empowering you to easily tweak your code before hackers can exploit it.
So get started today.
Dastidly, the free, lightweight Dast Scanner for your CI CD pipeline.
From Burp Suite.